what is the area of this figure and this
figure right over here is sometimes
called a kite for obvious reasons if you
tied some string here you might want to
fly it at the beach and another way to
think about what a kite is it's a
quadrilateral that is that is
that is symmetric around a line that is
symmetric around a diagonal so this
right over here is a diagonal of this
quadrilateral and it's symmetric around
it this top part and this bottom part
are mirror images and i think about how
we might find the area of it given that
we've been given essentially the width
of this kite and we've also been given
the height of this kite or if you view
this as a sideways kite you could be
this is the height and that the eight
centimeters as the width given that
we've got those dimensions how can we
actually figure out its area
so to do that let me actually
copy and paste half of the kite so this
is the bottom half of the kite
and then let's take the top half of the
kite
so let's take the top half of the kite
and split it up into sections so i have
this little red section here
i have this red section here and
actually i'm going to try to color the
i'm going to try to color the actual
the actual
lines here so that we can keep track of
those as well
so i'll make this line
green
and i'll make this line purple
so imagine taking this little triangle
right over here and actually let me do
let me do this one too in
blue so this one over here
is blue
you get the picture let me try to color
it in at least reasonably so color it in
and then i could make
i could make this line this segment
right over here i am going to make
orange
so let's start focusing on this red
triangle here imagine
imagine
flipping it over so imagine flipping it
over and then moving it down here so
what would it look like
well then the green side is going to now
be over here
this kind of mauve colored side is still
on the bottom
and my red triangle is going to look
something like this
my red triangle is going to look like
that
now let's do the same thing with this
bigger blue triangle let's flip it over
and then move it down here
so this green side since we flipped it
is now over here
and this orange
side is now
over here
is now over here and we have our
and we have
we have this blue right over here and
the reason that we know that it
definitely fits is the fact that it is
symmetric around this diagonal that this
length right over here is equivalent to
this length
right over here that's why it fits
perfectly like this
now this is what we just constructed is
clearly a rectangle a rectangle that is
14 centimeters wide
and not eight centimeters high it's half
of eight centimeters high so it's eight
centimeters times one half or four
centimeters high and we know how to find
the area of this
this is 4 centimeters times 14
centimeters so the area is equal to
4 centimeters
times 14 centimeters
which is equal to let's see that's 40
plus 16
56 square
centimeters so if you're taking the area
of a kite you're really just taking
one-half the width times the height or
one-half the width times the height any
way you want to think about it